- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey today, our message is
bet on your strengths.
Over to you, Gary Vaynerchuk.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- You need to bet on your
strengths, and don't give
a f-(omitted) about what you suck at.
Way too many people in this
room are going to spend
the next 30, 40 years of
their lives trying to check
the boxes of the things
that they're not as good at.
And that you're going to
waste a (omitted) load
of time and lose.
I highly recommend auditing
yourself, or if you have
no f-(omitted) empathy
or EQ or self-awareness,
then find somebody in
your family or friendship
that does, and let them
tell you who you are.
And once you believe
that, either for yourself,
or someone else told you,
go directly all chips
all in to that, because
that is the only possible
way, in my opinion,
watching from the outside...
Let me rephrase, that
is a very highly likely
way of over indexing because the truth is,
if you want to be an anomaly,
you've got to act like one.
And so that's it, that's what I got.
And so thanks for having me.
(audience laughing)
- So there's this great
story that I've told before
but I love it, so I want to tell it again,
about this rabbit who
goes to animal school.
And as he's going to animal
school, he learns all
the skills that he needs
to learn to be a successful
animal when he grows up.
And at the end of the
first year, he gets his
report card.
And on that report card,
he scores an A plus
in hopping, and he's
scoring an F in swimming.
And so his parents come home and they look
at the report card, and
they start shaming him,
and they say, how are
you failing in swimming?
You're a disgrace to the family.
You got to get trained.
We're going to hire you
coaches and extra practice
after school, and we're
going to make sure that you
do really well on swimming.
You're really good at
hopping, so don't worry
about that, just focus on the swimming.
And so for the next year,
he's focused and focused
and focused on swimming and
getting better and better
and better at it.
And in the process, he forgot how to hop.
And as for the swimming,
have you ever seen
a bunny that swam?
And so this is the
mindset that I think a lot
of people fall into, where
we get our report cards
from school or from life,
and we feel that we're
weak in certain areas,
and our default solution
for some reason is we
need to work on fixing
those weaknesses.
We want to be a well-rounded individual.
And what ends up happening is, you become
mediocre at everything,
and those things that
you potentially can be
world-class genius level
talent at, you don't do.
That's not how you have
success as an entrepreneur.
If you try to do everything
and you only spend
5% of your time doing the
thing that you could be
great at, you're always
going to be mediocre.
You're never going to get
the results that you want.
Success in business will
come from you focusing
on what you can be amazing
at, world-class at,
and spending as much time
doing that as possible.
And the rest, you eliminate, you automate,
or you delegate.
And as quickly as possible,
you want to figure out
how can I build a team
around me to complement
my weaknesses so I can go
all in on what I'm great at?
If I look at my YouTube
channel, at the start,
I did everything.
And I'm a big believer in
doing everything to get
things rolling.
I hate spending money
'til I'm making money,
but the first move that I made was to hire
an editor for my channel, because I wasn't
great at editing.
I had no interest in
it, it was not something
that I ever wanted to
be world-class level at.
And getting that editor allowed me to go
from one video a week, to one video a day.
Seven times my output by
hiring that one person.
It allowed me to spend more
time at what I was great at
and wanted to improve at.
And so when you see
people complaining about
their weaknesses, I'd
encourage you to think
and explain to them, don't worry about it.
What are you good at?
And spend as much time there as possible.
When you're doing a
self-analysis, look at what
do you have the ability to be world-class,
Michael Jordan-level talent at?
And then how do you spend 80% of your day
every day doing that work?
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is your greatest strength?
Leave it down in the comments
below, I'm super curious
to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Yael Forman,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means
a lot to me, and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
Thank you, guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- You need to know what
your unique strengths are
and be willing to delegate.
So I would say the question
of whether you should
take a skill, learn it
yourself, delegate it to
someone else or hire
a new team member, are
determined by having a very
accurate self-assessment,
and assessment of your team's skills.
Not only what you can do,
what you should be doing.
That's very important.
So if you're a startup CEO or founder,
and you have a team of
say, two to 10 people,
as soon as you have funds
to hire, you should not
be focused on the things
that you are bad at.
Sounds very, very
intuitive, but it is not,
because you might have
enough time to do those
things, but the question is,
do you have the attention
to dedicate to those things so
they're not an interruption?
Especially if you're a
venture-backed startup,
and you're competing
against other companies
that also have a lot of
funding, the game and the race
goes to the swift, so
you have to have a lot
of velocity.
- You talk about managing
your strengths, I know
one of my weak points
in my personal life is
I don't like technical stuff.
So even though I have to
be on Twitter and Instagram
and Facebook, I don't care for that.
So guess what?
I find somebody who loves to do that.
You know, I find somebody
who has a strength
where I have a weakness,
and I partner with 'em.
All you're trying to
do is get to the goal.
No one gets there by themselves.
Everybody needs help.
Now, when you know what
you got goin' for you,
be confident, not cocky.
Managing your strengths,
knowing what they are,
and don't let nobody talk you out of it.
And that gets you fight ready.
(audience applauding)
You get fight ready like that.
You got to know you.
Helps you develop your skills.
- A girl boss.
A girl boss is someone
who, I guess, takes charge
of her own life.
So it's a girl boss or a guy boss.
It's someone who knows their weaknesses
and knows what their strengths are
and knows how to play to their strengths.
I think there's a lot of people out there,
and I've interviewed a lot of them who...
My favorite interview question is
name your biggest strength
and your biggest weakness,
or what do you have to work on?
And the scariest people
are the ones who say
like, I show up early,
it's my biggest weakness.
Or like, I work too much,
And, you know, everybody
has things that they can
improve upon, and I think
a world where everybody's
more aware of that is
a good one, and a place
where people can be
empowered to make choices
in their life rather than throw themself
into places where they may not inherently
be successful, because the world has sold
them some story of what
they should be doing.
So I guess a girl boss is
someone who's in choice.